Our Pop Culture Lead.
Tis the
season for Christmas movies
from holiday classics
such as A Family Vacation.
That goes terribly wrong
when the Mccallister's realize
they left their son Kevin home a
Some crappy parents, by the way,
or all the life lessons
young Ralphie Parker
learns as he lobbies his parents
for the perfect present
in a Christmas Story.
But since its release in 1988,
there has been a hotly contested
Is Die Hard.
Really a Christmas movie?
And joining me now is Jeremy Arn
He is the author of Turner
Classic Movies Christmas in the
Jeremy, thank you for being here
And I should disclose, of course
the TCM is part of the Warner
Brothers Discovery family,
although that's not why I booked
Why I did will become a parent
in just a second.
But first, let's start
with the general theme.
How do you define a Christmas mo
Well,
the way I define
it is any movie of any genre
in which
the Christmas season plays
a meaningful role in the story.
So some some aspects,
some emotional truth of the seas
has to meaningfully inform the s
for the audience.
So the season means different th
It means joy and family, togethe
finding love and compassion
and positive transformation
can also mean loneliness, cynici
maybe a disgust with
the commercialism of the season.
So there's a very wide
spectrum of emotion
that we tie to the Christmas sea
which allows
for a great variety of movies
to become what I would call
Christmas movies.
You describe and I do not disagr
Frank Capra's It's A Wonderful L
as the Ultimate Christmas Movie,
which is it's
actually a pretty dark movie
when you get down
to what actually happens
in the alternative universe
in which George Bailey does not
Let's.
Obviously,
if you're if you've made it to 2
and you haven't seen It's
a Wonderful Life, I'm sorry.
But here's a little here's
a little spoiler that I want to
next year.
We can carry and
we
That's right.
I'm getting shivers just looking
So I guess the question I have f
you is,
can a Christmas movie as you def
Can it have a not happy ending?
That is a good question.
Up for debate.
And there are very few if any.
There are very few Christmas mov
that I consider
Christmas movies
that have downbeat endings.
One of them is a really unusual,
obscure film
noir from 1961 called Blast of S
Another, arguably a Christmas mo
is the James Bond picture
on Her Majesty's Secret Service.
Lazenby. George Lazenby.
I didn't
have you pegged this as a Lazenb
but you keep going.
I'm more of a Connery guy,
but okay, I'm a Connery guy.
But that's my favorite Bond movi
And, you know,
Bond falls in love and proposes
marriage on Christmas
Eve in a snowy barn.
The holidays worked into the sto
Let's get to the real reason
I had you here,
which is just the definitive pro
you have settled.
The arguments Die Hard is in thi
It gets its own chapter.
Die Hard is a Christmas movie.
I'm glad it is now official.
Explain why in your view.
Because there are
I don't know what to call them s
Let's let's be polite
and call them skeptics.
You say die hards. Not a Christm
Obviously it is. Explain why.
Well,
first of all, when people say di
hard is not a Christmas movie
and the other side
must be insane for thinking
it is what that dispute is reall
Is definition.
Both sides are defining
the term Christmas movie
very differently.
And so for someone,
it may really not be a Christmas
and that's fine for them.
But for the rest of us, it is.
And the reason I think it is,
is that it begins
as the most common type
of Christmas movie,
which is some version of a dysfu
or estranged family
trying to reconcile on Christmas
In this case, John and Holly McC
Holly, I'd like to know.
Yes. Her name's Holly.
Yes.
Changed from the source material
Her name is Stephanie.
So that is the story
that is
happening
before the terrorists come and t
Nakatomi Plaza
and what that does
is it grounds the audience
to see the whole movie
that follows through the prism
of this Christmas time
family reconciliation story
and a Christmas miracle, if I ma
Right.
There are references to Christma
all throughout the movie and the
and the visuals on the soundtrac
Sound effects Christmas.
Oh, no.
I've got a machine gun. Exactly.
Christmas,
I think, does a lot to lighten t
Die Hard, too.
It's a violent movie,
but it's not cruel
or unpleasantly violent.
It's it's cheerful and joyful,
and that connects it to the seas
Here's just a little clip
from the start of the film.
John McClane on his way
to visit Holly
and Holly in Los Angeles for Chr
the driver, Argyle, asks
if he wants to listen to some mu
don't work
Christmas music
is business music
on December 24.
But how to survive the doc
So one other point
I'd like to make the about the D
being a Christmas movie
and honestly I could do 2 hours
just on this
topic is the key moment of the f
John McClane and again,
this movie's been out for a litt
so I'm sorry, but spoiler alert
when John McClane saves the day,
saves his wife,
kills Hans Gruber and another ba
he's only able to do
because of the presence of prese
There are Christmas presents the
and he uses the tape.
I'm not going to
give more than that away.
But obviously, definitionally,
this could not have happened,
this miracle any other holiday.
It definitely makes us aware
of that connection in that momen
And here's the thing.
If Die Hard reset
at another time of year,
the story could still work.
You could still have this story.
But what Christmas does it
it enhances all these emotions
and rituals
that we recognize as linked to t
and intensifies them.
You know, Christmas
does that to the highs and the l
It's a wonderful life is powerfu
because the despair
that Jimmy Stewart feels
is so greatly enhanced by the fa
that he's feeling it at Christma
Yeah.
Die Hard
it could work on a day
other than Christmas,
but it would not be the same mov
Well, if it were Arbor Day,
then he wouldn't
have had the Christmas tape
and then Hollywood died.
That's pretty clear.
Jeremy Arnold,
the book is A Christmas in the M
Before you go,
what is your favorite Christmas
It's A Wonderful Life.
Yeah, because it's the ultimate
for the reasons we just don't.
Yeah, it's a beautiful film.
Thank you so much for being here
Really good to see you. Thank yo